مصطلح النقل الآني الكمي قد يبدو كأنه من عالم الخيال العلمي، لكن كما سنتحدث في حلقة اليوم
من Qiskit في الفصل، إنه تقنية حقيقية جداً ومفيدة جداً للاتصالات الكمية و
الشبكات. مرحباً بكم في Qiskit في الفصل. في هذه السلسلة، سنستخدم Qiskit لاستكشاف بعض المفاهيم الأساسية
التي تُغطى عادة في دورات متعلقة بالحوسبة الكمية. كل فيديو مصحوب بوحدة تفاعلية
مرتبطة في الوصف أدناه، فتأكد من الاطلاع عليها. النقل الآني هو نوع من كليشيه الخيال العلمي
والفنتازيا في هذه المرحلة. شخص أو جسم يختفي من مكان ويظهر فوراً في مكان آخر.
بقدر ما سيكون ذلك رائعاً، للأسف هذا النوع من النقل الآني على الأقل مستحيل. سيخرق الحد
الكوني للسرعة. لا شيء يمكنه السفر أسرع من الضوء. لكن النقل الآني الكمي
ممكن. في النقل الآني الكمي، المعلومات وليس المادة يمكن نقلها بين موقعين
بعيدين. كل ما تحتاجه هو زوج من الجسيمات المتشابكة، واحد في كل موقع، وطريقة لنقل المعلومات
الكلاسيكية بين الموقعين. هذا البروتوكول طُوّر عام 1993 بواسطة فريق
من علماء الكم، بمن فيهم Charles Bennett من IBM. أسموه النقل الآني الكمي لأنه مشابه
لنسخة الخيال العلمي، فالمعلومات الكمية اختفت من مكان وظهرت في مكان بعيد
آخر دون أن تسافر عبر الفضاء المتوسط. قد يبدو الأمر كالسحر، لكن كما سنرى، ليس هناك شيء
غامض أو سحري فيه. إنه مُمكّن بظاهرة التشابك الكمي مع الاتصال
الكلاسيكي. اليوم سنستعرض بروتوكول النقل الآني الكمي وكيف يعمل. ثم سنطبقه
عملياً على حاسوب كمي حقيقي لنقل حالة qubit من جانب من معالج IBM الكمي إلى
الجانب الآخر. إليكم كيف يعمل النقل الآني الكمي. لنفترض لدينا شخصان Alice وBob يفصل بينهما
مسافة كبيرة. لنقل أن Alice لديها qubit. سنسميه qubit Q للسهولة. وهو في
حالة كمية مجهولة sq حيث alpha 0 وalpha 1 أعداد
مركبة. Alice تريد إرسال حالتها إلى Bob، لكن ليس لديها طريقة لإرسال الـ qubit نفسه. قد يكون
بعيداً جداً، أو ربما لا تعرف حتى أين Bob بالضبط، فلا تعرف أين ترسله. لحسن الحظ،
يتشارك الصديقان بالفعل زوجاً من الـ qubit المتشابكة A وB، حيث Alice لديها qubit A وBob لديه qubit B. وهذه
الـ qubit متشابكة. بالتشابك أقصد أنه رغم أن الـ qubit الاثنين يفصل بينهما مسافة
كبيرة، فإن حالتيهما مترابطتان بطريقة لا تستطيع الفيزياء الكلاسيكية تفسيرها. هذا الزوج المتشابك
يُسمى ebit، ويمكننا استخدامه كمورد في الحوسبة والاتصالات الكمية.
في هذه الحالة، يمكن لـ Alice استخدام الـ ebit كمورد لنقل معلوماتها الكمية إلى Bob. لنرى كيف، دعونا
نبدأ بكتابة الحالة المشتركة لجميع هذه الـ qubit الثلاثة حيث رتبت الـ qubit بشكل اعتباطي نوعاً ما
عند هذه المرحلة، لكن هذا الترتيب سيكون مناسباً عند تشغيل تجربتنا على Qiskit. في Qiskit، الطريقة المعيارية
لترتيب الـ qubit هي من اليمين إلى اليسار. إذن حالة qubit صفر ستظهر على اليمين.
دعونا نوسع الحالة قليلاً ونعيد كتابتها هكذا. ثم الخطوة الأولى في بروتوكول النقل الآني هي
أن تشبّك Alice الـ qubit الخاص ببياناتها مع نصفها من الـ ebit باستخدام gate C-NOT. الـ gate C-NOT أو gate التحكم بالعكس
يغير حالة qubit واحد، وهو الـ qubit الهدف، بناءً على حالة qubit آخر، وهو الـ qubit المتحكم.
إذا كان الـ qubit المتحكم في الحالة صفر، فلا شيء يحدث للهدف. وإذا كان الـ qubit المتحكم في
الحالة واحد، فإن الـ qubit الهدف ينقلب. إذن في هذه الحالة، qubit بيانات Alice وهو Q سيكون الـ qubit المتحكم
وqubit الـ ebit الخاص بها A سيكون الـ qubit الهدف. الحدان الأولان لم يتغيرا أبداً بـ C-NOT، لكن
الحدين الأخيرين تغيرا لأن الـ qubit المتحكم Q كان في الحالة واحد. ثم تطبق Alice
gate Hadamard على qubit بياناتها Q الذي يأخذ الحالة 0 إلى الحالة 1/جذر2 ضرب (0+1) والحالة 1 إلى
1/جذر2 ضرب (0-1). سأتخطى بعض الجبر البسيط هنا والذي يمكنكم محاولة ملئه بأنفسكم إن أردتم.
لكن بعد إعادة ترتيب بعض الحدود ستحصلون على حالة تبدو هكذا. الآن حالة Alice وBob ذات الثلاث
qubit المتشابكة تبدو فوضوية تماماً. لكن انظروا ما يحدث إذا قاست Alice كلا الـ qubit الخاصين بها. حالة الثلاث
qubit ستنهار جزئياً إلى أحد هذه الحدود
الأربعة. وفي كل حالة، سيبقى Bob بحالة تراكب بسعات مرتبطة بحالة Alice
الأولية المجهولة. تذكروا أن السعات هي alpha 0 وalpha 1. إذن
مثلاً، إذا قاست Alice كلا الـ qubit بقيمة صفر، فستنهار حالة Bob إلى هذا الحد، الحالة
المجهولة الأصلية التي أرادت Alice نقلها آنياً. لكن إذا قاست Alice صفراً على qubit A وواحداً على qubit Q، فستكون حالة Bob
هذه. هذه الحالة يمكن تحويلها إلى الحالة الأصلية لـ qubit Q إذا طبق Bob
gate Z، الذي سيقلب هذه الإشارة هنا. لكن Bob لن يعرف أن يفعل ذلك
حتى يعلم ما قاسته Alice. الخطوة التالية في البروتوكول هي أن تتصل Alice بـ Bob وتخبره ما
كانت قياساتها الاثنان. بعد أن يعرف ذلك، سيعرف أي عمليات يجريها على الـ qubit الخاص به ليطابق
حالة Alice الأصلية. هذا جدول بالقياسات الأربعة الممكنة والعمليات الأربع الممكنة التي سيحتاج Bob
لإجرائها على الـ qubit الخاص به بناءً على تلك القياسات. قد يحتاج Bob لتطبيق gate Z أو gate X أو كليهما
لتحويل الـ qubit الخاص به ليطابق qubit Alice الأصلي. هذه الخطوة الأخيرة، حيث تتصل Alice بـ Bob، بالمناسبة هي السبب
في أن النقل الآني الكمي لا ينتهك السببية. رغم أن حالة Bob انهارت فوراً عندما قاست Alice
الـ qubit الخاصين بها، لم يستطع Bob استخراج أي معلومات من تلك الحالة حتى أخبرته Alice بما قاسته. وتلك
المكالمة محدودة بسرعة الضوء. مررنا للتو بكثير من الرياضيات التفصيلية، لذا قد تكون الحقيقة
المذهلة بأننا نقلنا معلومات كمية آنياً قد ضاعت. لكنها حقاً مدهشة. باستخدام
التشابك كمورد، استطاعت Alice إجراء قياس لتدمير المعلومات الكمية المخزنة عندها وجعلها تظهر
في موقع بعيد آخر مع Bob. هذه المسافة يمكن أن تكون مئات بل آلاف الكيلومترات. والأكثر
إدهاشاً أن هذا البروتوكول لا يتطلب حتى أن تعرف Alice أين Bob بالضبط. طالما يتشاركان ebit
ويمكنهما التواصل كلاسيكياً مع بعضهما، فإن النقل الآني الكمي سيعمل. الآن دعونا نرى كيف يعمل هذا
مع Qiskit وننقل فعلاً حالة كمية آنياً على حاسوب كمي.
سنبدأ بثلاث qubit، واحد لكل من qubit البيانات Q والـ qubit A وB التي ستشكل الـ ebit.
نبدأ بإنشاء الـ ebit. نطبق Hadamard على qubit A متبوعاً بـ C-NOT
بين A وB لإنشاء الحالة المتشابكة التي نريدها.
ثم نُعدّ qubit Alice وهو Q في حالة كمية عشوائية بتطبيق عملية أحادية عشوائية مُمثلة بهذا المربع المُسمى
U. ثم يأتي النقل الآني. أولاً C-NOT بين الـ qubit Q وA. ثم Hadamard على
qubit Q. ثم القياسات تُنهر الحالة جزئياً بحيث يبقى فقط qubit Bob وهو B في حالة تراكب.
هذه هي النقطة التي ستتصل فيها Alice بـ Bob وتخبره بما قاسته. ثم سيطبق Bob بعض
الـ gate بناءً على تلك القياسات. هذه المربعات ذات الحد الأحمر تعني gate مشروطة. الأول يعني
أن Bob يطبق gate X على الـ qubit الخاص به إذا قيس qubit A بقيمة واحد. والثاني
يعني أنه سيطبق gate Z أيضاً إذا قيس qubit Q بقيمة واحد.
الآن يجب أن يكون لدى Bob qubit في نفس الحالة التي كان فيها qubit Alice عند هذه النقطة هنا بعد gate العملية الأحادية.
إذا سار كل شيء كما هو مخطط، فنحن نقلنا الحالة الكمية آنياً. لكن كيف نتحقق من ذلك؟ يمكننا تشغيل
نفس الـ circuit لكن مع تغيير صغير واحد.
هنا أضفنا عملية أحادية أخرى في نهاية الـ circuit مطبقة على qubit Bob. هذه العملية الأحادية هي معكوس
تلك التي طبقناها في البداية على qubit Alice. المنطق هنا هو أنه إذا أنشأت هذه الـ gate الأولى
الحالة الكمية التي نُقلت آنياً إلى qubit Bob، فإن هذه يجب أن تلغيها وتعيد qubit Bob إلى حالة
الصفر. لكن بالطبع هذا يلغي كل عملنا الشاق في نقل الحالة آنياً. لذا لن نرغب في
فعل ذلك إذا أردنا فعلاً فعل شيء بالحالة المنقولة وإذا كانت فعلاً في حالة كمية
مجهولة، لن نتمكن من تطبيق عملية أحادية لإلغائها. على أي حال، هذا فقط لأغراض التشخيص للتأكد
من أن النقل الآني نجح. إذا قسنا qubit Bob في حالة الصفر، فيمكننا أن نكون واثقين بشكل
معقول أن النقل الآني نجح. بمجرد أن نتأكد أن البروتوكول يعمل كما هو متوقع، يمكننا إزالة هذه
العملية الأحادية الأخيرة وفعل شيء فعلي بالحالة المنقولة. لكن الآن، دعونا فقط نتأكد أنه يعمل.
دعونا ننفذ الـ circuit على حاسوب كمي. يمكننا استخدام بدائية العيّنات في Qiskit لتشغيل هذا الـ circuit
عدة مرات وجمع إحصائيات عن نتائج القياس. إذا نقلنا حالة Alice إلى Bob بشكل مثالي
في كل مرة، فسيقيس Bob الـ qubit الخاص به بقيمة صفر في كل مرة، لكن مع ضوضاء البيئة وعدم كمال
الـ gate، يمكننا أن نتوقع بعض التشغيلات حيث ينتهي qubit Bob بقيمة واحد. لكن طالما أن الغالبية
العظمى من الوقت يُقاس qubit Bob بقيمة صفر، يمكننا اعتبارها نجاحاً. هنا لدينا مدرج تكراري لنتائج القياس
لجميع الـ qubit الثلاث. قياس Bob يظهر في الخانة الأولى من كل سلسلة ثلاثية البتات. كما هو متوقع، النتائج
الأربع التي يكون فيها بته صفراً أكثر احتمالاً بكثير من الأربع الأخرى. إذن، لقد نقلنا
حالة كمية آنياً بنجاح. لكن انظروا كم نقلناها. هذه خريطة لجميع
الـ qubit على المعالج الكمي الذي استخدمناه. وفي التجربة، استخدمنا فقط هذه الـ qubit الثلاث.
qubit Alice كان هنا وqubit Bob كان هنا. إذن كانا تقريباً بجانب بعضهما. كان بإمكاننا
تحقيق نفس الشيء بتطبيق gate تبديل فقط، والتي كما يوحي الاسم تبدّل الحالات الكمية
لـ qubit متجاورتين. النقل الآني الكمي مفيد لنقل المعلومات الكمية لمسافات طويلة، وقد
تم نقل حالات كمية آنياً لمئات الكيلومترات سابقاً. لتجاربنا هنا، نحن محدودون بحجم
الشريحة، لكن يمكننا جعل النقل الآني أكثر إثارة للإعجاب بنقل حالة آنياً بين qubit
بعيدتين على حاسوبنا الكمي. لذا دعونا نجرب ذلك. هنا مخطط الـ circuit الجديد. يبدو أكثر
تعقيداً، لكن لم يتغير شيء جوهرياً إلا أن الآن Alice وBob ينشئان الـ ebit المشترك
ثم يفترقان. هذه السلسلة من الخطوط وعلامات X تمثل gate تبديل تنقل
حالتي Alice وBob من qubit إلى أخرى. Alice تتحرك للأعلى إلى qubit 1 و
Bob يتحرك للأسفل إلى qubit 12. ثم تنشئ Alice حالتها العشوائية على qubit 0 بهذه
العملية الأحادية. تذكروا أنها تنشئ الحالة بعد أن تكون هي وBob قد
افترقا بالفعل. إذن Bob بعيد عنها بالفعل.
ثم يستمر بروتوكول النقل الآني كما سبق وينتهي Bob بحالة Alice الأصلية بعد
عملياته المشروطة. نطبق gate العملية الأحادية المعكوسة ثم نتحقق من أن qubit Bob في
حالة الصفر. ومرة أخرى نرى أن الغالبية العظمى من الوقت كان qubit Bob في حالة
الصفر. إذن النقل الآني كان ناجحاً.
معدل النجاح ليس بنفس الارتفاع كما كان عندما كانت Alice وBob بجانب بعضهما. كل تلك الـ gate
التبديل يمكن أن تكون مكلفة وتسبب تدهور الـ ebit قليلاً. النقل الآني الكمي قد يبدو كالسحر، لكن كما
رأينا، كل ما يتطلبه هو التشابك، وقناة اتصال كلاسيكية، وبعض الذكاء. الاقتراح الأصلي لعام 1993
الذي غطيناه في هذا الفيديو شكّل الأساس لبروتوكولات أخرى مثل النقل الآني
للـ gate الكمية وهو مكون أساسي للحوسبة والاتصالات الكمية.
على الجبهة التجريبية، واصل العلماء دفع حدود النقل الآني الكمي، حتى أنهم نجحوا في نقل
الحالة الكمية لفوتون آنياً بين مختبر على الأرض وقمر صناعي على ارتفاع 1,400 كم
فوقه. ونقل حالات كمية آنياً عبر كابل إنترنت كلاسيكي مشوش. إذا أردت نقل حالتك
الكمية آنياً، توجه إلى وحدة النقل الآني الكمي المرتبطة في الوصف أدناه. شكراً للمشاهدة
وأراكم في المرة القادمة.